if the export sector grows and if it can
give the rest of the country a boost if
the overall mood improves a lot of if's
there so let's try and get some facts
now folker try chief economist at the
association of german chambers of
industry and commerce joins us now in
the studio a lot of uncertainty and now
the eu even discovered a huge budget
deficit in athens of some 2 billion
euros athens says it's not all that bad
and presents different figures what's
really going on there
the overall deficit figures of the greek
government is not that bad they have
even a
surplus in the primary we call economies
we call it primary deficit this means
the
expenditure without the interest
payments because the there's this huge
debt so there are good signs
concerning the the great
greek budget
but not overall in the greek economy and
greece will need more money now the
foreign ministers just said a few weeks
ago that under no circumstances greece
can implement even more
budget cuts
but that's exactly what the
international lenders will demand won't
they
i don't know whether they
are demanding more
budget cuts they are demanding more
reforms to raise the competitiveness i
mean we do did a lot of austerity
measures in
greece and maybe
there's no not much room left but in
order to
going on the privatization process the
flexibilization of the labor market or
increasing market access to certain
occupations there is room left
so you see a lot has been done already
but unfortunately it hasn't borne fruit
yet at least not when we look at athens
mountain of dead because that has been
steadily climbing only the haircut in
2011 as we can see here now in a graphic
provided a little more breathing space
but that was only very briefly since
then the country's been accumulating
even more debt it's now reached almost
180 of gross domestic product
maybe another haircut
the interest payments
which would be triggered if
greece is going to the free capital
market would be prohibited
prohibitive
but now they are under the umbrella of
the european stability mechanism so we
the richer countries are lending them
money and there is no need to discuss
right now about another haircut but
let's
face it in two years
maybe there is the need for a haircut or
for some measures in order to prolong
the interest payments or to to
cut the interest rates itself there is a
need for that okay well let's hope that
greece and the greek people can last
that long
thank you very much for joining us
you